the internet is going off when it comes
to christopher maloney's signature cake
and he's not mad about it makes me feel
really good
earlier this week the actor was spotted
chatting with co-star danielle monet
truett on the set of law and order
organized crime
when fans noticed the actor wearing
extremely fitted navy pants posing with
one leg up
further showing off his assets i mean
that's really rare
christopher acknowledged the social
media moment by responding to a tweet
writing
chris you want to explain why you have
so much cake to which he wrote
sure big birthday 60 big boy
200 pounds big cake and he didn't stop
there
when another fan asked sir why are you
trending at chris maloney
he responded the other maloneys are
trending not me
aside from showing off his figure
christopher has been delivering when it
comes to making his return
as elliot stabler in law and order svu
after nearly 10 years away
are you sorry for leaving
or are you sorry for walking
for not giving me the courtesy of
telling me
both you were the most
single most important person
in my life and while we keep our fingers
crossed for more stabler and olivia
benson together on screen
we will be seeing a lot more of stabler
on the new spin-off
law order organized crime i'm waiting
stand down detective
story espento detective
every one of you
[Applause]
in august chris told e.t why returning
to the franchise felt like it was meant
to be
certain pieces just fell into place and
i'll say a big component of it was
a personal for me there was just
personal things and i was like you know
now is a good time
um um i don't know
that you know that was it there was uh
nothing secret it just
was effortlessly correct
for now another person who's thrilled
with stapler's return
chris's co-star dylan mcdermott who told
et in march how he's been adjusting on
set
and what it was like working alongside
the law and order veteran
chris is a great guy and we've had fun
together
and he's so well suited for his
character
and such a perfect fit for him and
you know me going up against him
certainly
on the show is such a fun thing and
so you know we've had a lot of fun he's
completely excited so happy to be back
you know it's been what
10 12 years or something he couldn't be
more happy
you